Russia steps up missile attacks on cues
and Ukrainian troops make territorial
gains in the East Vladimir zlinski
secures more weapons from Western allies
but will it make a difference on the
battlefield and does diplomacy stand a
chance this isn't tight story
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Nastasia Tay 15 months into Russia's
invasion of Ukraine President Vladimir
zielinski has secured further military
support from Western allies they
promised more weapons training and money
but stopped short of providing the F-16
fighter jets that he says could be a
game changer as Russia escalates its
missile attacks ahead of an expected
Ukrainian counter-offensive six African
leaders are now planning a peace mission
to Moscow and Kiev so what are the
interests at stake and how could they
shift political alliances we'll explore
those issues with our guests shortly but
first this report by Katie Lopez horian
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
had a long wish list for his three-day
European tour much of it was granted
with leaders promising billions of
dollars worth of missiles tanks and
drones
we're returning home with new military
help newer and more powerful weapons for
the front lines and more protection for
our people we also have greater
political support
however his request for F-16 fighter
jets has been rejected with pilot
training programs offered instead which
will mean that we're training Ukrainian
citizens to become absolutely combat
ready aircraft pilots and particularly
whether it comes to Nato tactics as well
because that's an important part of the
long-term relationship between our
countries
Western allies notably U.S President Joe
Biden are hesitant to supply key with
American-made weapons that can reach
Russian soil but solensky insists the
weapons are vital to defend Ukraine
against escalated airstrikes
the latest offer to mediate comes from
African nations a delegation of six
countries including Egypt and South
Africa is set to meet the Russian and
Ukrainian leaders soon President Putin
and president zelenski
agreed that they would be willing to
receive the mission of the African heads
of states in both Moscow and Kiev most
African nations have abstained from
voting on U.N resolutions condemning The
Invasion Russia has been building close
ties with States in Africa since the
conflict began and Ukraine is one of the
biggest exporters of wheat to the
continent
15 months into the war the list of
countries attempting to broker peace
between Russia and Ukraine is spreading
across regions
for Inside Story
[Music]
well let's bring in our guests in Kiev
we have Peter zalmayev he is the
executive director of the Eurasia
democracy initiative a non-profit
organization that promotes democracy and
post-communist transitional Societies in
London Samuel Romanian he's an associate
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute leading UK defense and
security Think Tank Samuel is also the
author of Putin's war on Ukraine
and in the Russian Capital Moscow we
have Vladimir sodnikov he's an associate
professor of international relations at
the higher School of economics
University and also a specialist on
Russian Foreign Affairs a warm welcome
to you all and thanks so much for
joining us on inside story now President
Vladimir zielinski has just come back
from his Grand European tour asking for
more weapons so I want to start there as
Katia just reported he's gotten a lot of
what's on his wish list but not these
F-16 fighter jets at least not yet Pisa
was it a success
yeah I think overall it was a great
success and I think you know than the
fact that uh our president has collected
these uh essentially pledges by member
states of NATO including France a
crucial player uh that supports uh
Ukraine's eventual membership and NATO
was very important you know and I would
probably discount at this point the
importance of app 16 uh short term
because obviously it will take not not
weeks but months to get our Pilots
trained uh so this may be a little bit
of a you know uh red herring you know uh
and you know what what is important is
to get it as much of a artillery support
uh tanks uh you know electronic uh
um devices Etc that Ukraine needs in
order to Stage a successful
counter-offensive F-16 is very important
and you know what I believe they will be
coming eventually uh for whatever post
you know War uh security Arrangement is
found for Ukraine and long term I think
Ukraine needs them but short term I
think Ukraine it will be tough it won't
be overnight but I think Ukraine's
counter-offensive can be successful
without f-16s well we've seen quite a
robust round of weapons commitments it's
obviously a very fine line for Western
countries they want to support Kiev but
they also don't want to do something
that would escalate the war Vladimir how
is this latest round of commitments
being viewed in Moscow uh thank you very
much for having me on your show once
again I think that actually uh all the
offers so all the colleges which my
Ukrainian colleague was mentioning
uh in case
um in his view actually they are not
very much welcome they they in fact they
they they are not welcomed in Moscow I
think that uh Russia actually will uh
utilize all possible efforts uh
including strikes which we have seen
just now I mean in in the previous night
and before that uh and also I think uh
the
um situation will be then there with the
strikes will be reoriented on the
transfer uh roots of these tanks uh I'm
not sure I'm not sure at all that uh uh
the United States or some European
Alliance of the United States are going
to a really Supply Ukraine with F-16
um fighter bombers because that means
that uh the serious weapon is already
engaged in the one the war will be
escalating so I I I don't uh I'm not
sure that the European allies and the
United States would like to escalate for
the installation of the world so I think
that
um at the end of the day uh Russia will
uh undertake all the necessary measures
to uh cope with the problems of the
western backed supplies of sophisticated
Weaponry to Ukraine sure but it doesn't
sound like Moscow necessarily views this
as an escalation uh Samuel you're
sitting in London the UK has said that
they're going to be supplying long-range
missiles to Ukraine which would cover
more distance than what Ukraine
currently has how much of a difference
do you think these weapons will actually
make to fighting on the ground and
strategy
so I think that Britain has already
supplied these Storm Shadow missiles and
the Russians have said that the Storm
Shadow missiles were already put onto
the battlefield with the strike that we
saw last week in luhansk so uh these are
also going to be paired with additional
drone Technologies obviously the
ukrainians have been wanting long-range
missiles for a long time they've wanted
out of camps in the United States but
there have been some concerns obviously
in Western capitals that Ukraine might
use them outside of just the occupied
Ukrainian regions but actually to strike
Russian territory proper so Ukraine made
an assurance to Britain that it wouldn't
do that and then it got these long range
of missiles so I think that it's a
significant Advantage for the Iranian
cause and also it's interesting that
they've been very swiftly integrated
onto the battlefield unlike the f-16s as
we just mentioned which you could take
months to enter the battlefield
I mean I just want to follow up there
the lion that give
possibly that it's not attacking Russian
territory and your assessment of the war
so far how true is that
well I mean it depends on what you
define as actual defensive actions I
mean obviously Vladimir zielinski and
his team around it have categorically
denied that they're striking targets
inside Russia but we've seen some uh
anecdotes and some suggestions to the
contrary I think there were some
interesting leaks for example that came
through from The Washington Post uh
suggested that zelensity was at least
mulling uh occupying Russian Villages
and and striking the Jerusalem pipeline
towards Hungary and uh also there was a
plan from his advisory Circle to strike
Syria aslensky put a put the brakes on
and it also recurrent to shellings and
attacks that we're seeing inside
Belgrade and briennese and Kursk near
the borders of Russia and even further
on which could have been triggered by uh
Ukrainian attacks and infiltration
Behind Enemy Lines obviously though if
they're targeting Logistics in the
military of Russia from inside that
could be deemed as a defensive operation
in a sense because that's preventing the
Russians from striking Ukrainian cities
but the Russians would probably take
that as an escalation so it really
depends on how you define defensive and
offensive action Ukraine denies striking
Russia but to some contextual evidence
that they have been engaged in those
type of activities so Peter I see you
nodding there that's your assessment too
I would just say that in response to the
previous uh panelists and the Russian uh
participant uh that you know for Russia
Russia considers and can consider
anything is escalatory considering that
the occupied territory where Ukraine is
hoping to stay just counter-offensive
including personas of Parisian the Nets
and Crimea they are already according to
the Russian Constitution part of the
Russian territory and there's no
difference between Moscow and uh Crimea
in the izava uh Russian lawmaker or a
Russian politician or a Russian military
person so uh you know it's very much a
moot point at this point after we've
seen time and again the way Russia has
reacted to these escalatory tactics you
know they have thrown everything they
have at Ukraine I wish our co-pantalists
from Russia experienced at least one
night the sort of night we experienced
three days ago with woken up at three in
the morning and all hell breaks loose
over you literally what it felt like
your rooftop you know so I I at this
point I don't understand what that
escalation that uh Russia is warning
about could mean short of a nuclear war
so I wouldn't put too much stock in it
and you know uh sorry I do want to ask
you about something that you said a
moment ago which was well your
suggestion that Kiev doesn't need these
f-16s to win the war you talked about
them being used in a post-war context
right I'm curious about why Kiev wants
these f-16s and I understand that there
are air facilities in Ukraine very very
few of them that could actually handle
the Jets obviously as you suggested as
well a huge amount of training is this
about symbolism or is it actually about
strategy well you know I think it's uh
once again it's tied in with the longer
uh turn strategy of security for Ukraine
Ukraine is very mindful that we're
dealing with when it comes to our allies
in the west members of the Ramstein
Coalition NATO States uh these are
electoral democracies and the Winds of
democracy below are very capricious one
day today they're blowing One Direction
tomorrow they'll be blowing a different
direction to put it bluntly ukrainians
are of you know concerned about
um you know the these winds in
Washington whether they will Shift come
uh the elections in 2024 if election if
Republicans or Donald Trump take power
again then you know all bets are off and
so this is a way to get in as much
weaponry and as many security guarantees
as possible before those inevitable uh
Winds of Change you know set in in the
US and other Western capitals so anxiety
Then potentially
given the context nt-24 election
Vladimir I'm curious about how that's
going over and how that's sitting at the
moment in Moscow
yeah excuse me excuse me I I just want
to make a point to the previous reply of
Ukrainian guests actually uh I would
also would like to for you to know that
uh uh he you you will get the experience
on having sustained uh continuous
bombardment of the Ukrainian drones uh
on the bulgarity actually remember my my
my close relatives lives there and they
have small children so sorry to say that
but actually they had to abandon their
houses because of Ukrainian drones were
bombarding by the Rockets so far the uh
near near side area so that's actually
also an experience probably for you will
be yes and another thing I would like to
point out uh that uh
Moscow actually uh is not fearing the
Ukrainian accounts so-called counts
offensive at all I mean uh we are
concentrating our troops and I heard in
the news that but the total amount of
the troops will be on maybe around 500
000 so uh one thing another point is
that uh the
um Russia Russia actually is making
tactics as far as I can understand in
the
um waging the
um combatant uh combat operations
actually Russia is giving the floor to
professionals to professionals like uh
private company private military company
and the Wagner company actually is doing
their job right so I think that at the
end of the day my point that I'm
absolutely sure of that that if and when
this uh so-called Ukrainian uh Council
offense it would take place and I
anticipate it would take place probably
in a week or in a month in between this
beauty videos so I don't it's all that
Ukraine will get much of advantages and
much superiority and much Gates thank
you gentlemen I feel like this is a good
time to take a bit of a look at who
controls what on the ground at the
moment Ukraine says it continues to make
gains in the East specifically around
the eastern city of bakmut Fighters
belonging to Russia's Wagner group hold
most of that City the site of one of the
longest and bloodiest battles of this
war and Russia meanwhile says it's
carried out several ground attacks along
the Donetsk front now Vladimir you were
just saying there that Wagner's been
doing an excellent job there were recent
reports or rumors that well disputed
reports that Wagner had been actually
sharing intelligence with Kiev I know
Kiev denies this but regardless of all
of that there's there's you can't deny
that there's been a huge amount of
disunity on the Russian front
well actually I think this is rubbish I
think I don't know where you get this
information but I think this information
that Wagner group is sharing some
intelligence information with Ukrainian
military I think that's a completely
wrong a wrong a wrong wrong assumption
right you know Mr pregosian who is the
chief of the Wagner group he's not going
to be uh say a predator well let's say
to be to be a traitor for uh for his own
country and that's one thing another
thing I think uh sorry what was the
second part of your question I I just
bought it well no so I understand that
these are disputed reports sir but there
have been huge amounts of disputes
between Wagner and the Russian military
very public ones over the last few weeks
and months particularly around bakwas
you can't say that there's a huge amount
of unity in in the fighting forces there
uh well yes yes I agree with you there
were some reports that are related in uh
here in Russia in Moscow uh that uh
there were uh reports that uh there is
uh some uh ongoing battles uh uh in uh
in North Thomasville but as you call it
so but uh I think that there was
information and I'm just reiterating
myself again that the huge uh huge
amounts of uh troops of the Russian
troops uh will be uh are going to be
amassed along the all the front line
which is uh quite uh quite a fixed line
actually right now and the moral I think
that the the war actually uh Ukrainian
Russian war is at the moment of a
position War then uh no side is going
just to
um undertake something without the march
of preparation okay well let's talk
about this counter-offensive that we
expect to happen uh Samuel from previous
Ukrainian strategies do you envision
this to be more about trying to retake
territory potentially or taking out like
different strategic targets instead how
intense could this fighting get
well I think it is counter-offensive is
going to be important in terms of the
teaching of territory and what we're
already seeing is uh some limited uh
movements in a variety of potential axes
as well as what the United States calls
shaping operations which are preventing
and derailing Russia's ability to
retaliate for Ukrainian advances so
we're basically seeing some shaping
operations take shape in parts of
Separation such as Taco Mac which could
lead to a broader assault on the city of
Topo and if the ukrainians do manage to
liberate melatopo they will be able to
disrupt the Russian Supply chains uh
further from Crimea towards Don vas
another area where the ukrainians are
trying to expand is in luhansk
particularly along the axis being
swadova and permina there's heavy
Russian fortifications there but Ukraine
is making slow but steady gains over
there over the course of the past
several weeks and then there's what
we've been just noticing in bakboot
where the ukrainians have managed to
take advantage of the fact that the
water group forces are concentrated on
Urban battles in the city center and
they've been able to liberate 20 square
kilometers on the northern and southern
flanks so I think that there'll be a
multiple access counter-offensive where
they liberate territory and they combine
that with attacks on Russian Logistics
both in the occupied territories and
perhaps deniably inside Russia itself so
it sounds like preparations are very
much in place I'm curious about how this
is being viewed and key because as we've
been talking about there have been these
escalating missile strikes on the
capital over the course of recent days
Peter you were just describing them
yourself is that viewed there as a
reflection of Moscow being worried about
the counter-offensive or is it about
preempting it
yes indeed uh It Is by all indications
uh very uh troubles Troublesome time for
uh for for Moscow mind you uh that a
drone attack on the Kremlin was the
first time that this impregnable uh up
until then a pregnantable fortress uh in
the heart of the country in the heart of
its capital was breached you know the
first time was in 1986 when a German
violent Matthias rooster landed on the
Red Square so a scandal of major
proportions and throughout Russia we've
seen starting you know last summer a
Spate of uh arson's uh fire attacks uh
attacks on various
um or oil depositories military uh
military uh objects and just a few days
ago of three helicopters and two planes
shot down over the bronsk area as they
were on route to attack uh Ukrainian
essentially City civilians all down in
one day and just yesterday a milestone
was reached 200 000 Russian soldiers as
reported by the Ukraine's defense
Ministry uh have died in this war which
is 10 times the number of Soviet
soldiers who died in the war in
Afghanistan in 10 years so yes uh
Russians are and the Kremlin is very
very uh concerned about the coming
Contra offensive and uh obviously these
are a lot of them are retaliatory
um attacks these shellings on Kiev which
you would doubt about their efficacy and
but their you know what their purpose is
because ukrainians have shown that you
know a tremendous success rate shooting
down these missiles including uh the
missile that's that Vladimir Putin has
claimed could not be shot down and which
is kinjal and the Patriots that have
been delivered to Ukraine are now uh
being shown to successfully disable even
these Hypersonic missiles okay I want to
take a bit of a step back here at this
point because it's been a year and a
quarter 15 months since this War Began I
know Moscow has been releasing policy
documents about countering the West
broadly and they hardly mention Ukraine
but surely this is viewed as part of
that is this war being viewed as part of
broader Russian foreign policy and
therefore Moscow is in it for the Long
Haul
well actually uh yes there was a concept
a concept A New Concept of a Russian
foreign policy Luke and the problem uh
for us actually that uh really uh that
is uh proxy war by the Western countries
as this policy document the same so uh
and uh I think that the relations
between Russia and the Western countries
I I'm not telling only about the United
States or or say uh European United
States European Alliance like Germany
France and others I think these
relations have been spoiled for for
years to come so I think that Ukrainian
uh conflict actually uh was one of the
protects protects of for for publishing
this document but another thing also I
would like to add that since 2014 it
became clear that Russia is not going to
be accepted by the Western countries in
terms we which are the how they it
conducts its foreign policy so I I think
that there's no wonder that this new
policy document actually appeared and uh
I think that it's gonna be uh uh
probably another documents like another
Concepts uh soon when when uh the there
will be a continuation of this one so it
does feel though like the Kremlin is
waste it's playing a bit of a waiting
game to see how long Western Unity will
last and it has held so far Samuel I
want to ask you just a little more about
the f-16s because I recall Ukraine got
their tanks from the West in March like
six months before that sending tanks
would have been seen as a huge
escalation do you think that that might
be the same case and when it comes to
the f-16s that it's really just a matter
of time and that Western Unity will hold
long enough for that to happen
yeah I think that Dad they building on
the past blind it does seem as if the
Russians are counting on Western
disunity still even though the West has
remained remarkably United during this
war we just saw Sergey lavrov yesterday
for example just uh remind uh
International audiences about the fact
that the U.S abandoned the Afghan
government and let the Taliban take over
in 2021 and implying that something
similar could happen with regards to U.S
support for Ukraine turning towards the
specifics of the f-16s I think it's more
and more likely that the United States
will eventually uh Cave on supplying
these as well as other atacabs towards
the Ukrainian Army long-range missiles
are being restricted because of Supply
constraints according to Mark Valley not
because of escalation risks and the
f-16s are probably due to the fact that
they're just not going to arrive in time
for the current counter-offensive so I
think that the more the country start
training Ukrainian Pilots to use them
like the British training efforts the
Belgian training efforts and many others
that we've noticed over the course of
the past a couple of weeks including
Jerry zielinski's tour and it seems that
the Ukraine is prepared to use them then
I think that the f-16s will eventually
enter the battlefield and one last point
it's important to keep in mind that this
Ukrainian counter offensive regardless
of whether it succeeds or how much it
succeeds or fails is not going to be
probably the last one in this war the
Russians are in this Hall as are the
ukrainians and the f-16s could come into
effect during another counter offenses
that the Iranians much in the future
sure well if everyone's in it for the
long haul let me ask them about the
ongoing mediation efforts China's now
got a mediation effort going African
leaders are on their way to Moscow and
Kiev the Pope Francis wants to get
involved as well Peter how is this
viewed in queue is any of this going
anywhere
uh TF obviously cannot antagonize China
considering what a crucial player it is
in world's Affairs and it's making
efforts to you know good faith efforts
to engage with China who's special
representative was just in Kiev
um you know having said that Ukraine is
wary that China is also Guided by the uh
it's imperative to not allow Putin to
lose uh Faith or uh to lose uh the war
too dramatically because of Vladimir
putness is in beans governments are
alike in that they uh have challenged
the liberal World Order led by the
United States and the allies and so
these uh you know various Peace Keeping
initiatives and uh you know that we see
coming not just from China but from
Brazil and from most recently from South
Africa these are all members of the
so-called brics uh which is a grouping
of countries where Russia is also a part
of and so Ukraine has officially to
welcome it but once again I think we are
very very concerned about the
impartiality of these players and the
way they're trying to keep Vladimir
Putin's face intact you mentioned
impartiality there let me ask very very
briefly Vladimir to come in on that how
is the African Peace initiative at the
moment being viewed in Moscow
well actually thank you very much for
your question it's really an important
question I think that uh it has been
welcomed actually the Russian foreign
minister just today published a
statement which uh it says that uh
Moscow is welcoming this initiative and
I think that
there will be really a tops but during
the visit of this African nation uh to
Moscow there will be talks not only
between the head of the delegation but
also uh and the Russian foreign Ministry
but also I think the President
Putin will accept them uh another thing
I just want to make one point very
shortly I will just one my point if any
plan will not be uh including any uh
anything which is not suitable for
Russia I think the peaceful negotiations
won't be success at all so they will
fail I I hope oh I hope that this
African leads the nation I'm not sure
familiar with the details of the plan
but I hope that this uh African
delegation African Mission have a
realistic plan of a peaceful settlement
of this
well we'll leave the discussion there
for now there's plenty more to talk
about but thank you to all of our guests
Peter zamiev Samuel Romani and Vladimir
satnikov and thank you too for watching
you can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website that's altazira.com
and for further discussion do go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story remember
you can also join the conversation on
Twitter our handle is at AJ Inside Story
for me Anastasia today and the whole
team here bye for now
foreign